This right here is Apple’s new $1300 base
13” MacBook Pro that finally comes with
a quad-core processor, and we’re gonna connect
it to the same eGPU that we previously connected
to the top-spec 15” MacBook Pro, where we
concluded that adding an eGPU wasn’t worth
it.
But as you’ll see in this video, we’re
completely changing our mind because this
$2000 setup works like a dream.
So for the eGPU system, we’re using the
$300 Razer Core X with a $400 Radeon Vega
64 graphics card, and combined with the new
$1299 base 13” MacBook Pro, that makes for
a total of $2,000 for this setup compared
to $3,549 for the top-spec 15” MacBook Pro.
Now of course, the 15” model is gonna get
it’s high performance wherever it goes,
while the 13” needs to be connected to the
eGPU to get the performance we’re about
to show you, but a lot of people actually
prefer the portability of the 13” for when
they’re on the go, so this setup makes a
lot of sense.
And even without an eGPU, the new $1300 13”
base MacBook Pro actually performs very well,
and we’ll be comparing it directly to the
$1800 13” Pro very soon, so if you’re
not already subscribed, do that now.
And without further ado, let’s get into
performance.
In Geekbench 4’s graphics test, we can see
that we now get a lot more graphics performance
than the 15” MacBook Pro now that we’re
using the eGPU.
And in Unigine Heaven, a gaming benchmark,
we’re now getting almost double the gaming
performance compared to the 15” model with
Vega 20 graphics, so if you’re wanting to
game on a MacBook Pro, this is the perfect
one for an eGPU.
Now let’s move onto some video editing tests
in Final Cut Pro, which do a great job of
utilizing both graphics and processor performance.
Let’s start with the BruceX benchmark, which
almost purely uses graphics, and as you can
see, the eGPU setup is actually finishing
faster than the $3500 MacBook Pro!
And now on video stabilization of 4K footage,
it’s also finishing slightly faster than
15” Pro, once again, and it’s actually
5x faster than the integrated graphics alone.
So those tests were mainly using graphics
performance, which we know is faster with
the eGPU, but now let’s do some tasks that
also use up a good amount of processing performance
as well.
I’d first like to mention that the top-spec
15” model gets an 8-core i9 CPU which is
obviously much much faster than the 1.4GHz
quad-core in the $1300 base model, but let’s
give it a chance, starting with editing common
4K footage with a couple of effects and LUTs
added to it.
This is basically what most YouTubers are
gonna be editing if they’re shooting in
4K.
And we see here that the base MacBook Pro
with the eGPU is actually not too far off
from the 15”, so this is really impressive
for paying only $2000 compared to $3500.
And interestingly, when we previously added
the eGPU to that same 15” Pro, it actually
took longer for some reason, around the same
time as the 13” Pro with the eGPU, so we’re
getting a lot more out of it.
Now let’s move onto some heavy duty footage,
C200 4K RAW at 60 frames per second, we actually
got a massive improvement with the eGPU connected,
exporting around 3 times as fast, and not
too far behind the 15” MacBook Pro.
And not only that, but when we playback the
timeline, the eGPU triples the amount of FPS
we get while editing, almost as much as the
high-end model alone, so it actually becomes
bearable to edit this footage.
And now exporting 4.5K R3D RAW, footage that’s
extremely processor heavy, we’re actually
seeing another massive improvement with the
eGPU.
We’re still not quite at the 15” Pro’s
level, but it beats waiting over 40 minutes
to export this clip.
Those were only a few limited video editing
tests, but we’re extremely surprised that
we’re getting this much performance out
of the base $1300 MacBook Pro with a $700
eGPU.
And the biggest difference was in tasks that
use mainly the graphics, like gaming and graphics
rendering, so if you’re doing work that’s
heavily dependent on graphics performance,
than this $2000 system is for you!
But the most impressive thing was how we also
saw a major difference in processor heavy
tasks as well, and the reason for that is
because the quad-core processor was being
held back by the limited performance of the
integrated graphics, and the eGPU gave the
CPU all the room it needed to perform at its
best.
And need I remind you that this MacBook only
has 8GB of RAM and it’s performing this
well, so if you’re gonna upgrade anything,
upgrade the RAM, absolutely don’t pay $300
for the i7 upgrade.
So at only $1300, I’m officially crowning
the 2019 13” base MacBook Pro, the best
MacBook you can get if you’re gonna use
an eGPU, and also as the overall best value
MacBook out of any MacBook we’ve seen in
years.
We’ve also tested a lot of eGPU systems
and this Razer Core X enclosure combined with
the Radeon Vega 64 is the best bang for the
buck eGPU system we’ve seen.
We also have AMD’s brand new Radeon 5700
XT in the office, but we won’t be able to
test it until we get driver support, hopefully
in macOS Catalina this fall.
And if you’re wondering how this $1300 MacBook
Pro compares to the $1800 2.4GHz model, that
video is coming very soon, so if you’re
not already subscribed, click that circle
above so you don’t miss out on that video.
Tap like if you enjoyed this video, and check
out one of those two videos right there.
Thanks for watching, and we’ll see you in
the next one!